guy came here Uber driver right he was
like one of those Chinese drivers so his
English was really really bad and then I
never try to let people know that I
speak Chinese so that I have that
distance so we it makes sense though it
really makes sense cuz then they'll pull
like the whole Chinese card what's the
Chinese card good question like they'll
go beyond the rules now I like that
professionalism you know if you're my
real estate agent stay my real estate
agent don't be like hey uh you want to
play soccer with my son I'm like no I
don't want soccer
with he'll like light a cigarette
immediately if you know lines get
crossed hella
Chinese yeah massage this side and then
go this
side I don't want any of that